so in this section of the lectures we're
going to move
from estimating um simple rep
representations of treatment effect
heterogeneity like
the case in causal trees to estimating
flexible
functional forms for kate's for the tau
of x
and when we think about why we'd want to
have these flexible
functional forms why would we want to
have a smooth non-parametric estimate
tau of x
there's a variety of motivations one is
that
we might want to understand partial
effects we might want to understand how
treatment effects change if i hold some
x's fixed and i change others
another motivation is that we're going
to use these as an
input into estimation of lower
dimensional objects
like we're going to use estimates of
kates in order to
pick the highest kate individuals and
assign them to a treatment
or we might use them to estimate optimal
policies so they can either be of
interest in their own right
or they can be an input into another
type of estimation problem
so to get started let's think about a
baseline method for estimating
flexibly tau of x the conditional
and using k n n the estimator for tau of
x
is constructed by first for the target x
the
the realization little x that you're
trying to go for
you take the k closest treated
observations take the sample mean
then you take the k closest control
observations
take the sample mean and then you take
the difference between the two
and we'll use this to construct an
estimate of tau hat of x
so an advantage of this method is it's
very straightforward to understand
what's going on
and it's actually got good robust
performance when the number of
covariates is small
but a challenge with it is it's got an
acute curse of dimensionality
even for relatively small
numbers of covariates say if we have 20
covariates and 20
000 observations the cursive
dimensionality
starts to kick in another version of
this
is a kernel regression and you can think
of a kernel regression as a
generalization of k and n
in this case for a given x we're finding
putting
equal weight on all the nearest
neighbors to x
and zero weight elsewhere a kernel is
going to take a weighted average of
nearby treated observations
but it's going to weight closer
observations more highly
and farther away observations less so
but it's going to just do similarly a
weighted average of observations that
are treated near x
minus a weighted average of observations
that are near x but are control
observations
now let's talk about random forests and
we're going to interpret random forests
in a way that's a little different than
standard
we're going to interpret it as adaptive
nearest neighbor matching
so random forests are a popular
heuristic for adaptive nearest neighbor
estimation
they were introduced by brymen in 2001
and they actually have an excellent
empirical track record and they're often
used as a black box and we don't and
they work well out of out of the box if
you don't tune them they tend to still
perform pretty well so they're one of
the fastest high performing machine
learning methods you can get coded up
but we we often use them without really
understanding
why they work or how to evaluate their
performance
in the early 2000s there were several
people that started thinking about
using various types of forest methods
for treatment effects
affect estimation but without formal
theory
um what we what um stefan wagger and i
did in stefan's job market paper
was provide the first formal results
allowing random forests to be
used if with provably valid asymptotic
inference
so what we did was we figured out how to
um
how we can modify forest algorithms in
order to make them usable for inference
and those were the first results for
prediction with forests of that sort um
and then
we extended those to estimate causal
effects as well
so to understand how a causal forest
works let's start with the causal tree
so we've already covered causal trees
they define
neighborhoods for matching based on
recursive partitioning
and they advocate for sample splitting
to ensure that we get assumption-free
confidence intervals for treatment
effects in each leaf
and so we can contrast tree based
neighborhoods with
k and n on the right we see this picture
where for a target x we're going to
understand the treatment effect
estimates for x based on
the sample average treatment effect for
observations in the same
leaf as x so we'll use recursive
partitioning
using our um and if it's causal
inference using our
our um causal inference splitting rule
we'll come up with this partition of the
x base and then
we'll for estimate the treatment effect
for x on a separate
estimation sample based on the
observations in the same leaf
if we contrast that to nearest neighbor
matching
we would take a target x we would draw a
circle around that so we would find
all observations that are closest to x
and then we would again get the sample
average treatment effect for those
observations that are nearby
x now how do you go from trees to
forests
well again imagine we have a training
set um with covariates x
outcome y treatment assignment w and a
test point
and suppose we have a a tree predictor
so we've estimated say a causal tree and
for
for the particular value of x we have a
predictor
based on a tree the random forest idea
is to build and average many different
trees
so our estimate of tau hat of x can be
an average over many trees of
estimates of of treatment effects
now how do we turn a single tree
predictor into having lots of different
trees
well there's a variety of ways one is
bagging or sub sampling the training set
and this can be this is helpful for
smoothing over discontinuities
so when we have a single tree remember
that you know if x is near the boundary
then the estimate for the treatment
effect for x can change discontinuously
if we change x
across the boundary um
now the literature is but try both
bagging and sub sampling we're going to
focus on subsampling because that's
going to give us nicer statistical
properties
another thing that that's often done to
make each tree different from one
another
is to focus on a subset of covariates
for each tree and that because we're
using different covariates to build each
tree
we'll get different trees now the
literature actually
often focuses more on bagging and a lot
of that's the fault setting in a lot of
random forest packages
but sub sampling is particularly nice
because if we take
a subsample of the observations to
construct a tree
we can then get can get estimates by
taking a second subsample
and that's going to make each of our our
trees honest
uh and if we average up a bunch of
honest trees
we'll get unbiased estimates
so honest trees don't use the same data
to select the partition and make
predictions
so what we're going to do is build
forest out of those kinds of
honest trees and so the
main result in blogger and at 2018
is that when we when we build forests by
averaging up a bunch of honest trees
using sump sampling under some technical
conditions
then as the number of observations goes
to infinity
the the estimates are going to be
asymptotically normal and centered
around the truth
that allows us to for example construct
confidence intervals
so to see an example of how this works
in practice let's imagine we have 20 000
observations
we have uniformly distributed features
and six covariates
and treatment assignment is random and
suppose that all of the signal is
concentrated along two features
so the rest have four of the x's are
kind of noise covariates and two of them
actually affect treatment effects
so we look over here first on the left
we see
a plot a heat map of the true effect so
we've got this non-linear relationship
and treatment effects
are bigger in this right
upper corner and lower elsewhere
we see that when we use causal forest to
estimate this
these treatment effects we pick up the
this nonlinear shape although you can
see it's a little bit
boxy relative to the truth and that's
coming from
the fact that the forest is an average
of trees
we look over here at the knn estimate
and we see that the estimates are a bit
smeared
and that's because in six dimensions
what that what we're what we're
looking for are neighbors that are
similar in all six dimensions
but only two dimensions matter so in
order to get close in the other four
dimensions which the model doesn't know
don't matter
we have to be somewhat farther away in
two dimensions while the causal forest
is going to
use this adaptive splitting rule it's
going to figure out which covariates are
important to split on when building
trees
so it's going to construct neighborhoods
that are based on
on x1 and x2 and not the noise
covariates
so this these figures illustrate the
cursive dimensionality
now we try the same exercise with 20 000
observations
um we see the causal forest now it's
it's actually extra sharp and
we've got it's kind of too sharp in
terms of understanding the boundary of
treatment effects
but the k n estimate is incredibly
smeared now
we're trying to find k nearest neighbors
where the neighbors are nearby in 20
dimensions
and it just doesn't work so again we see
the advantage of adaptivity
the trees which are targeting treatment
effect heterogeneity
zero in on the right covariates and are
able to do a much better job
discriminating treatment effects
heterogeneity than the k n approach
so we can look here and see how well
calibrated the models
are and we see that in on the left when
we look at what causal forest
we see the things look very well
calibrated that is on the x-axis we have
true treatment effects and on the y-axis
we have estimated treatment effects
and they're lining up on the 45 degree
line which means that estimates are
close to truth
now we do see a little bit of issue here
around the
the boundaries where there's clearly
some
bias going on here and that's coming
from the fact that the
the trees are still having a hard time
building
neighborhoods near the boundaries that
discriminate well enough among
the different um the the different
values
of the treatment effects we see a much
bigger problem over here with the k n
model
where it's not nearly as well valid that
um
calibrated on the right
so there's actually been a fair number
of applications of of causal forest
already
one by uh hitchhim misra looking at
using causal ferrous for us to target
catalog mailings
another one by davis and heller
analyzing heterogeneous
impacts of summer jobs and then a little
bit later i'll tell you about one that
i've worked on with neil kelleher and
jan spiess
looking at applications for financial
aid
but first let's jump in to a
more stylized example the general social
survey
so the general social survey again is an
extensive survey collected since 1972
that
measures demographics political views
and social attitudes of the u.s
population
and there was a question that was
randomized where some
individuals were asked about whether
we're spending
too much money on welfare while others
were asked if we're spending too much on
assistance to the poor
again those are the same thing and so
the question is is seeing how does
wording the question affect the answers
so here's how we can think about
analyzing this and here we're going to
use the grf package
later on we'll talk a little bit more
about grf which is basically a
generalization of causal forests
so here's the r code that runs the model
and here's how
here's the the step where we actually
estimate the causal forest
so the first thing we do is we look and
make sure in our data that it looks like
this really was randomized
so we estimated propensity scores and
with those propensity scores
we then can see how what's the
distribution of estimated propensity
scores in the control group versus the
treatment group
and we see that the estimated propensity
scores all are very concentrated around
0.5 and they look similar in the control
in the treatment group
and that's basically what you would
expect if in fact their
everybody was randomized 50 50.
next we look at the out-of-bag
conditional average treatment effect and
we look at the
histogram that shows the distribution of
those so
what we're showing here on the x-axis is
the estimated kate
and on the y-axis is the count and so we
see this nice distribution
where it looks like there's a fair bit
of heterogeneity in kate's
sometimes the the treatment effect is as
high as
0.5 other times it's as low as about
0.25
so it looks like our model has found
that there is systematic heterogeneity
and treatment effects
however we don't know yet how well
calibrated our model is and we want to
be very skeptical because there are many
many
uh examples uh where we're in a low
signal environment
and there actually aren't real uh
treatment affects heterogeneity in the
data generating process
so here it looks like there's
heterogeneity but of course even if
there was no heterogeneity
we would still estimate some dispersion
just like we did with the propensity
scores due to
sampling variation so our next question
is is this heterogeneity that
appears here is it actually real and we
can we can figure that out by
using estimating the model and a
training set and then looking at what
happens in a test set
but before we do that let's take a look
at calibration using an approach based
on regression
so we're going to use this uh
method that was formalized in in
chernozikov at all 2018
that's related to this transformed
outcome approach
that we uh suggested in atheism 2016.
so here what we're doing is we're
running a regression
um we're doing a best linear fit using
the forest predictions on held out
and we're going to do this regression on
held out data
and so the regressors are going to be
the estimated kate
so for each observation we're going to
we're going to look at
a transformed outcome that represents
treatment effects on the left hand side
actual treatment effects and the held
out data
and on the right hand side we're going
to have the kate
and what we're going to look at here is
what is the
coefficient is 1.57
9 on the kate and so this differential
forest prediction
is basically the kate minus the 8.
and it looks like we have a coefficient
of 1.57
first of all that's different than zero
which is good which means that it looks
like
when our estimated kate changes
that is positively correlated with
actual as treatment effects and we can
also
we can reject that it's one though it
says that this is not perfectly
calibrated
and we can also reject that this
coefficient is zero
which says that there's actually
treatment effect heterogeneity
a related exercise we can do is to
basically break the data into four
quartiles of estimated kates
and then look in held out data to see
for each quartile of kate what is the
estimated
treatment effect for each of those
quartiles and
we can put confidence intervals around
those so
exactly what we do is we go through k
folds of the data
for fold little k we hold out that fold
and on the rest of the data
we estimate a model of kate for example
using
causal forests and then using that
those estimates we define a mapping from
covariates to the quartiles of the k
distribution so
for every x we assign them 1 2 3 4
based on where they are in the
distribution of case
once we have that estimated we can apply
that to the covariate values x
in fold k so
that way we've used data outside of fold
k in order to build a model
which we use to assign the units in
group k to quartiles
if i go through this and loop through
the case
across all the folds then at the end of
looping through all the folds
each observation has been assigned to
one of the four quartiles
and that assignment doesn't depend on
that unit's outcomes
crucially if that's the case
then we can average up across everybody
that's been assigned to quartile 4 or
average up across everybody who's been
assigned to quartile one
the treatment effects so that's we can
for example
the orange or the sample ate that is for
each quartile we just take the sample
average treated minus the sample average
control to get the estimate of treatment
effects and then we just construct
standard errors in the usual way
and what we see here is we have some
evidence of heterogeneity
so it looks like you know the high
quartiles are above the low quartiles
but it's also pretty hard to tell the
difference between quartile three
and quartile four so we're but we are
able to just
to discriminate um quartile one versus
two and two versus three
the next question we might wanna ask is
okay it's great to understand we can
tell things apart but what predicts
whether you're
in a high quartile or a low quartile so
here actually we've we've divided things
even finer
we've done the same kind of exercise but
now we're looking at deciles
and so what we do in this table is for
decile 1 the low treatment effects we
look at all the covariates
of those individuals and average them up
and we can compare those to all the
value
average values of the covariates for
units in the 10th
decile and we see on in the
final column here we test the hypothesis
that those means are equal
and they're different for all the
covariates
except for this uh this other value of
political views
and so if we if we then try to interpret
this
we're able to say okay it looks like
there's older people
um are in the tenth uh decile
so that's saying that older people have
higher treatment effects for older
people it matters more whether it's
welfare or assistance to the poor
higher income people are in the highest
decile
they're lower education but it's not um
it's not as big a gap here and then we
see with political views
the the low political views are
left-leaning and the high political
views are right-leaning
the treatment effects are um are higher
for the right leaning people
and they're higher for men also
and so this way of understanding the
groups it avoids some of the pitfalls of
trying to
inspect a tree and deciding what's in
what's important
and actually in the machine learning
literature for for us there's often
these measures of variable importance
which says how often do the trees split
on a variable
we're not giving that that type of set
of analysis here and it's actually not
really a good idea to do that
because again with variable importance
it can you can split on one variable
but say income and education are highly
correlated could be you split on income
all the time
but that you could have split on
education and gotten a similar
set of neighborhoods or a similar
partition so here
we've done it more descriptively we've
just said let's look at the
characteristics of people in decile 10
i don't really care if you split on
education or if you split on income
but i i can i'm i'm looking at the
people that you've picked out
now one thing that's interesting here is
actually income and education go in a
bit of an opposite direction
so saying it doesn't matter which one
you use is not actually true in this
data set
but it might in a different might be
similar in a different problem
so this figure depicts partial effects
it basically says we're going to hold
fixed co all covariates and we're just
going to change
liberals or conservative spectrum and
the less income to more income
spectrum and what this picture depicts
is that
there first of all the relationships are
non-linear so there's sort of
interactions between political views
and your income and then we also see
high conditional average treatment
effects for
high income more conservative people and
low conditional average treatment
effects for liberal and less rich people
now we'll consider another experiment
this one
was uh analyzed in a collaboration
between stanford ids 42
and the city university of newark new
york and the research questions
were about nudging people to fill out
financial aid forms and trying to
understand for whom nudges are effective
and how well different targeting
approaches do
so the experiment was run in 2017 and
2018 by ideas42
and cuny the control group you got
business as usual emails from the
college
while the treatment groups got
supplementary behavioral emails and text
messages
the people in the study were
matriculated students from cuny
community colleges
who had not yet renewed fosfa in
february of the study year
in 2017 there were 25 000 students from
three colleges in the experiment and in
40 000 students from five colleges and
so
when analyzing this data the average
treatment effect showed that the on-time
submission of financial aid increases
by in percentage points 6.4 percentage
points in 2017
and 12.1 in 2018 and that
increased early filing rates from 37 to
43 and 38 to 50 percent respectively
so this was a successful experiment just
to see what the experiment looked like
the text messages were sent um and they
would say things like hi
this is your student persistence team we
want to send you a few
help helpful texts and then we would
then they would give
text about renewing their financial aid
forms
so one of the first things we do is
estimate a causal forest to estimate
heterogeneous treatment effects
and this get these estimates tau hat and
then again we look at calibration using
the transformed outcome approach
we put on the left side the transformed
outcome and we regress that
on tau hat of x and what we see
is that the um that
the slope estimates are significantly
different than zero
so when we run regressions you're going
to test the hypothesis
about whether the coefficient is zero
and these p-values are all less than .05
so they're all statistically
significantly different from zero
but they're pretty noisy and we also see
that the estimates are are also far away
from one so we
see there's evidence of heterogeneity
but we see this model is not very
well calibrated if it was very well
calibrated then
if we regress the transform outcome on
tau hat of
x we should get a coefficient of one
treatment effect should be lining up
with estimated treatment effects
so again we're going to do this type of
quartile exercise again we're going to
hold out one fold of data k
build a model of kate on the remaining
data and use that model to build a drive
model mapping x to each of four
quartiles
based on the the tau hats from from this
uh this uh um
the k th iteration we're going to put
the observations into the four quartiles
in the held out fold and then we'll
finally estimate the average treatment
effect in each of the four quartiles for
fold k
using the outcomes in fold k
and to make use of all our data we're
going to do this exercise across all
folds of the data
which is called cross fitting so we'll
average the ates for a given quartile
across folds
so here's the results we look in 2017
and 2018
and unlike the general social survey
we're seeing
results are a lot noisier here so first
of all actually
in 2018 as you go from the first to the
second quartile
what we would be hoping is that the
average treatment effect should be going
up
our model says quartile 2 has higher
treatment effects than quartile one
but in held out data that's not holding
up
so we're basically saying we can ident
what this picture looks like in 2018
is we can tell apart kind of high
treatment effect
people the top half of treatment effects
in the bottom half of treatment effects
but we can't tell very well the
difference between
quartile 3 and 4 and we can't tell the
difference between quartiles 1 and 2.
well in 2017 we're able to pick out
quartile 1
but we're not able to distinguish
between the top three quartiles
and somewhat sadly this type of picture
is relatively common
this is this is showing a low signal
environment that is
the the there's more noise than there is
signal
and so when when there's a lot of noise
and there's not a lot of signal the
causal forest is kind of just
picking up random stuff due to sampling
variation it's not
actually distinguishing very well
treatment effects
now there's some distinguishing here
this isn't nothing and again in the
regression analysis we saw there was a
significant relationship
between actual treatment effects and
estimated treatment effects
but it's not super strong and that's
what we're seeing
playing out in this picture so when we
look at which x's are most
associated with kate heterogeneity
enrollment statuses
is the top covariate and to think about
this
some students have actually dropped out
so if they were students at the
beginning of the year but they've
dropped out by february they're less
likely to consider enrolling them the
next year
and so there's going to be a low
conditional average treatment effect
because
they're not interested in enrolling
therefore they're not interested in
filling out financial aid
and it turns out if we'd started with
this hypothesis we would have identified
strong heterogeneity
if you just distinguish the enrolled and
unenrolled students we see
high treatment effect estimates for the
enrolled students
now the treatment effects are not zero
for the unenrolled students and that's
because a lot of students actually come
and go from community college
and some that have dropped out are
planning to come back the next year
but the ones who are nudged um more
strongly
i mean who are enrolled are have have a
stronger effect of the nudge
i also want to emphasize that machine
learning kind of comes at a cost here
because we use data to search for
heterogeneity and that added some noise
which and that noise can actually
dominate in a low signal environment
well if we just focus on this
pre-specified hypothesis about an
enrollment we would find clear
separation in terms of
of treatment effects
now the last exercise i want to do here
is to look at
using these treatment effect estimates
to target
a treatment assignment so we imagine
that it's expensive
to to send texts then we want to think
about targeting
only z percent of individuals so in this
picture here the percent treated is on
the x-axis
and what we're going to what we're going
to show here is what is the benefit
of treating z percent of individuals
where z is on the x
axis relative to randomly assigning
treatment
now let's focus on this pink line first
just to orient ourselves to the graph
we've estimated positive treatment
effects so the benefit
of treating more people
if the treatment is randomly assigned is
just linear
so if a hundred percent were treated we
would we would get this
um estimate of uh of enrollment
i mean in the estimate of filling out
financial aid forms
that that's um what we estimate
for 100 treated so on
the y-axis is how many people enroll so
our estimates show that if we randomly
assigned treatment
if we if um to people
that as we get more people assigned each
of them is going to get that treatment
effect and then at the end
if 100 of people are treated we'll get
the um we'll get these uh
about 43 of students actually filling
out financial aid
now these other bars look at what the
enrollment rates would be if we use
other targeting policies
so this olive line here is corresponding
to what happens if we
target people according to kate and so
if we look for example
at the first say 12 and a half percent
if we targeted those
according if we picked that 12 and a
half percent to be the highest kate
people
instead of randomly assigning 12 and a
half percent to a treatment
then we're going to do better we're
going to have higher enrollments if we
target the treatment to the high cape
people
then actually the olive line kind of
hugs close to this purple line and
that's saying actually
if we tried to target say you know
30 of the people targeting high kate is
about as good as just randomly targeting
people
so their our targeting policy isn't that
effective um then we start to see more
separation again
up at these higher percentages so for
some reason we had a budget of treating
again it looks better to do targeting to
the top kate people
rather than randomly assigning the
treatment
but now what are these other pictures
well
we can then compete look at what if we
just targeted based on enrollment so we
first
sent the the um text to people
who were um who were uh
enrolled um and and we can think about
doing that
for um enrollment or we actually could
evaluate it for
inverse enrollment um so
we can uh we can look at that and
actually
targeting by enrollment
looks like it does pretty well
especially up in the higher
the higher targeting percentages
we finally can look at
a baseline and baseline is basically you
know
the gonna be the baseline prediction
of whether you're going to not fill out
your form
so suppose we targeted people who
weren't going to fill out the form which
kind of seems intuitive we target we say
hey people who we think we're not going
to fill out the form
will send them text and that'll make
them fill out the form
but it turns out here this that's this
red line here that's
that's significantly worse than just
targeting randomly
so we don't want to target people who
were had a baseline
predicted probability of not filling out
the form
on the flip side of that if we this kind
of
aqua line up here that's targeting
people
who we predicted were already pretty
likely to fill out the form
but it turns out the nudge works best on
the people who are already pretty likely
to fill out the form
and so we see that this this this aqua
line is is higher than the
the pink line and what that's saying is
targeting
by people who were um who were
most likely to fill out the form already
will be an effective targeting policy
so summarizing this picture is sort of
showing how you can use
something like a kate estimate as an
input to something else in this case
targeting people for text messages
so i've shown a bunch of examples of
forests for causal effects now they're
they're not the only
method that can be used and indeed they
may not be the most appropriate in every
circumstance
for example many economic data sets have
smooth relationships
relationships might be monotonic or
u-shaped
while forests actually try to fit a line
as a step function which is very
inefficient
a variety of machine learning methods
might improve upon this but sometimes
their little theory
for example you know neural nets might
be a good way to go but we don't
necessarily
have um you know reliable statistical
properties of them
so one solution that i've worked on with
a former graduate student rena freeburg
was to
introduce what we called local linear
forests
so to see what goes wrong with forest
here's a picture
there's a true relationship between y
and x which is illustrated with a black
line
and then we look at how what are the
predictions on a test set
of random forests and we see here
that when there's lots of dimensions and
the forest
might get confused and it ends up
fitting a step function
uh to this curve which doesn't look very
good especially for high values of x
um what we'll what we'll call a local
linear forest corrects for that so let
me show you how
um actually before i do that let me also
show the difference between a causal
forest and local linear forest
in the example of the general research
survey where there was the randomization
of the treatment
remember the treatment was what do you
ask about assistance before
the poor versus do you like welfare
and what we see here on the x-axis is
how liberal or conservative you are on
the left
and we see that the causal forest kind
of gets flat near the boundaries
and that's because it's the average of
trees and the trees are
having to build leaves that are big
enough to have observations in them
and so when you get towards the
boundaries you're averaging
only data points say to the to the left
of the
right boundary which tends to kind of
flatten out the curves
but what we call the local linear force
does a better job of
um of of maintaining this relationship
which
turns out it fits better when we look at
test sets
and it does a better job of fitting the
true relationship we see a similar
problem with
income that the causal forest flattens
out a little bit towards the edges while
the local linear forest does not
so how does it do that well basically it
it
thinks about running a regression a
weighted regression
and the weights are determined by
how how close uh points are to
the target point um in
leaves of the forest and so but but then
the the method also includes it's a
regression
and so it we're going to actually
estimate a slope coefficient
that says how does x affect y and by
estimating those slope coefficients
we're able to adjust for the slope of
the of the data generating process
near the near boundaries so if a data
point is near a boundary
we're going to under we're going to
actually estimate the slope of the
relationship between
x and y near that boundary and even
though we don't have data sets
on the other side of the we don't have
data points on the other side of the
boundary
we're able to predict what happens at
the boundary better
by understanding the relationship
between y and x say it's increasing as
you lead up to the boundary
you'll be able to do a better job
fitting and so we have a theorem that
says that this
works well